大家好,今天我给大家试试批量修改的使用方法。登录软件以后可以看到一个工作台,工作台这里可以选择要修改的内容。
左边的列表点开也可以进行选择,批量修改分为三种修改方法。分别是,全店批量修改,选择商品修改和上传文件修改。
那么三种修改方法都是支持定时修改的。下面我用批改标题为大家进行示范。
点击全店修改,这里可以选择商品的状态,是出售中还是仓库中,也可以根据自己的需求进行选择。
如果什么都不选,直接点击没问题,下一步,默认的就是选择全店的产品。
这里,设置你要修改的内容,点击立即修改或者定时修改。
如果对定时修改的时间要求比较高,建议大家在选择商品这里进行修改。
因为这里的时间更精准,速度也更快。
选择商品修改,我们选择好商品以后,点击批量工具,设置修改内容。
比如,未来三天,我要在零点到一点要求标题上有大醋这两个关键字,其他时间没有大醋。
那么我可以设置在左边添加大醋这个关键字,添加好了以后,点击确定。
我们可以看到标题已经变成了我们想要的样子了,然后点击定时修改。
选择批量设置多个时间,选择未来三天。
零点的时候进行修改,点击确定。
就可以了,这里可以查看提交的任务。
然后我们设置第二个任务。
第二个任务是删除大醋,也就是恢复原来的标题。
那么现在的标题就是原来的标题,我们直接点击定时修改就可以。
选择每天的一点钟变成原来的样子,点击确定就可以。
点击查看提交任务。
我们可以看到这里的任务都在列表里面。
任务是按照执行时间排序的。
那么第一个任务是添加大醋,然后到一点钟删除。
再到零点钟添加,再到一点钟删除,以此类推。
最后给大家演示一下上传文件修改。
上传文件修改需要下载一个模板。
时间关系模板我提前设置好了。
我们选择文件,然后点击立即修改。
这里可以查看提交的任务显示正在处理。
可以查看修改记录,显示已经成功了。
由于其他修改内容的使用方法是基本相同的,就不再进行示范了。
感謝大家的使用 祝大家生意新樓